Please welcome Kelly Marie Tran.
(audience applauding)
Hello.
Hi.
Oh my gosh, I am such a fan of you.
I'm so excited to be talking to you (laughs).
Oh, my daughters and I are freaking out that you're here.
And there was so many things
I couldn't wait to discuss with you.
I loved how you talked about that Raya is a warrior
and not just a princess.
And I did a film called "Ever After"
that was like a spin on "Cinderella"
because we need to be told not to wait to be rescued,
but to rescue ourselves and maybe even others
while we're at it.
So, what spoke to you about getting to be Disney's new
first Southeast Asian warrior princess?
I'm just so excited to be part of the movie.
Like you said, that sort of broadening the narrative
when it comes to what do people think
when they think of the word princess?
What do people think when they think of the word hero?
And recognizing that
I think you've had a very narrow perception
of what those words mean.
And now to be sort of part of that change
and recognizing that Raya, like you said,
is a character who very much saves herself
and also is working to save a lot other people around her.
I think that is really important
and it's really cool to be a part of.
I also know that you are the first Asian woman
to be in these "Star Wars" movies.
Talk about history, we all grew up on "Star Wars"
and you're the first?
I suppose it should have been earlier,
but thank you for being the first.
Gosh, "Star Wars" is such like a big thing
for so many people, and to have been a part of that
really meant a lot to me.
And I think we've talked a lot about what it means
to be the first fill in the blank all the time.
And I think for me, it's really exciting to be part of,
but also recognizing that I hope that I'm not the last
to be able to do this.
You are also a first on the cover of "Vanity Fair"
for "Star Wars".
You are breaking so many important glass ceilings
and paving the way for others.
And I understand that "Mulan" Disney's first Asian princess,
also a staple in my household.
I've seen it a billion times and we love it.
That that was something that was an inspiration to you.
Yeah, that was such a huge part of my childhood.
I think I was nine when that movie came out
and it was the first time I felt like I saw someone
who looked like me living in these sort of spaces
on that sort of scale.
And Ming-Na Wen who plays Mulan
is such an inspiration to me.
And I actually got to meet her at the episode nine premier.
And she's such a symbol of all the things that I wanna be.
It's such a cool experience.
Well, Ming-Na are you there?
(Kelly gasps)
Hello?
Oh my God, what?
(all laugh)
Kelly, hi Drew.
Hi, Ming-Na.
Hello everyone.
(audience applauding)
Hi beautiful princess warrior.
Wow, you did not tell me this was happening.
I'm probably gonna cry a little bit.
Hi, how are you.
Oh, look at you.
Oh my gosh, how are you doing?
I'm doing great.
Congratulations on everything.
I feel like I'm looking in a mirror,
like at the younger, because I followed Kelly's footsteps
and became part of the Star Wars family.
And now she's followed my footsteps
in being a Disney princess.
I just feel like we have this whole mirror thing going on
and I love it.
I know.
And I'm so proud of you.
And I'm also geek, so you're going to have to sign my doll.
Yeah!
Okay?
I love that.
These are collectibles for a reason,
because they are symbols.
I mean, we're talking about Disney princesses
you are Mulan and Raya.
These are the faces, the embodiments, the voices
and the realization of people seeing themselves in you both.
And Kelly, I know that you actually got off social media
because you were having a hard time during "Star Wars",
because people felt in the cyber world,
entitled and enabled to say things that were not kind.
I would love to ask you guys
in the face of what everybody is going through right now
in the Asian community,
do you have any advice out there for any girl, woman
or any age in between who might be watching this,
of how to find their superhero strength
in this time right now?
I think what Drew was asking about the anti-Asian hate
that's out there.
I mean the anti-Asian hate out there is...
I have a daughter who's 20
and she's going to college in New York.
And as a mother, is a great fear.
It's a constant fear.
And it kinda boggles my mind a little bit
that it's happening still.
So, I really hope your film "Raya",
as "Mulan" has done, it crosses all barriers.
It's about finding the hero and the heroine in all of us.
It's about believing in yourself.
And it's also about having compassion
and sharing the love to fight for humanity
and fight for what's right?
So, you know all those messages is really, really important.
And I think "Raya" is gonna provide that
for the new generation.
And I'm very grateful for that.
And thank you Drew for asking that question.
It's a very serious question.
And I'm just also geeking out a little bit about you Drew.
Oh my gosh!
You have given us so much.
I mean, seriously, your career.
Talk about storytelling and offering so much joy
and entertainment as well as,
just you know, you're my idol.
Thank you.
You're amazing.
That moves me so much.
We love you Drew!
I just want all girls to believe that we are equal
and that we have all the strengths
and capabilities and possibilities.
So, I honor the women who prove that narrative to be true
such as yourselves.
So, thank you so much for being here today.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
All right, air hug.
Also in honor of bravery and resilience
that you guys have shown and everyone,
we wanna also just contribute $5,000
to the Stop AAPI Hate organization,
an incredible organization that promotes equality
and provides resources for the Asian American
and Pacific Islander community.
And that is just a humble thank you
towards an organization that is doing incredible things.
Ming-Na Wen and Kelly Marie Tran, "Mulan"
and "Raya The Last Dragon" is in theaters and on Disney+
with premier access on March 5th.
It's incredible, we loved it.
And we love both of you.
(upbeat music)